are you hoping to see from conference
well look I think the test that
everyone's been talking about for the
last week is whether or not the
government is basically being fiscally
responsible I think there's another test
at Conservative Party Conference the
government set out in this growth plan
nobody's really paid any attention to it
but a set of reforms to drive growth
that are normally not the kind of
reforms you hear from the conservative
party immigration reform to make sure we
have the skills we need planning reform
very often conservative councils not
supportive of planning reform Net Zero
is back in fashion onshore wind is back
in fashion now that's what businesses
around the country were quite heartened
by but we are nervous as to whether or
not the conservatives really mean what
they say so I'm hoping this week to hear
a little bit more from the chancellor
the Prime Minister and in The Fringe
meetings that really the conservative
party do put two and a half percent
growth of primary importance to those
other conservative predilections
policies preferences that's interesting
actually isn't it because look this is
government it's all about going for
growth and yet the two things that
you've been talking about there
immigration and planning reform as well
I mean they are in particular things
that is quite difficult for
conservatives to push through do you
think there might be a bit of opposition
to that yes I think there might be and
look those are probably the two things
that come up most with businesses around
the country in terms of what do we need
to drive growth everybody is short of
Labor and skills and everybody is trying
to get projects moving in a country
that's hard to get them moving now full
credit to the chancellor and the Prime
Minister for putting that in their plan
uh and I think we'll all be wanting to
see that they really mean what they say
what what's what is your sense on that
you know because the Home Secretary
Suella Brotherman has talked about
driving immigration controlling
immigration levels keeping them down are
you have you had any sense from the
Prime Minister herself that she is
prepared to look at immigration well not
yet other than the chancellor raised it
and said they're going to be proposals
coming forward look everybody knows and
we saw this at last Conservative Party
Conference last year that we aren't
going to have uncontrolled immigration
and there isn't a business in the the
country that's looking for uncontrolled
immigration but the idea that you can
overnight close down the borders and not
allow in critical skills that we clearly
aren't going to grow in Britain soon
that's just putting growth second not
first and surely now after the events of
the last week the lesson is growth comes
first not second and you see believe
crochet conferenced many other people
would say right now that inflation
should come first they're looking at
their household bills and they're deeply
deeply concerned they're looking at
what's happened to mortgages and they
are frankly terrified about what will
happen if they are up for a renewal
anytime soon
and surely the biggest tax cutting
program for half a century is
Stoke inflation
well I think it it raises two risks
doesn't it the first is inflationary and
the second is and I think this is what
the markets were reacting to that it
undermines your ability to bring down
debt in the long run and I think that's
right so you have to look at whether or
not these tax cuts are going to drive
growth now we don't comment a lot on
personal income tax it's not really our
business I'm not convinced those cuts
are going to drive growth so just to be
Crystal Clear yeah you're talking about
the decision to scrap the additional
rate of tax for everyone earning over
150 000 you don't think that will really
move the Garland if you ask me for 30
measures that are going to drive up
growth I wouldn't put it in the top 30.
now the chancellor may feel differently
he might want to set out why he thinks
it's going to stimulate growth at the
same time clearly reversing employers
National Insurance clearly not putting
up corporation tax by six points those
things will be helpful to growth and
competitiveness so look I think there's
a lot of reasons why the markets uh find
the budget not credible I think you're
alluding to some of them that are right
but I think the chance to the Prime
Minister now need to come forward and
explain explain
what they've done why they've done it
why they think it'll work and at the
very least not row back from some of the
commitments that they have made to
supply side reform
um how about spending cuts
um are you concerned about the idea
about a cutting spending yes but look I
think when you borrow 600 billion pounds
if you take the 450 of the pandemic the
150 of the energy crisis you're trying
to bring down debt in the medium term
you're clearly going to have a plan
that's going to have a mix of spending
cuts perhaps some tax Rises I would have
thought as well as some growth now the
exact balance of that we are awake to
hear what the government's view is but
I'd be surprised if you could keep
growing public spending as fast as you
can but you need to be careful because
we all know that after the pandemic
there are critical public services that
need to be restored that's why the
medium term plan is going to be tough
work tough work
um it's there a fairness argument out
here as well I know you obviously speak
on health of businesses that businesses
employ people don't know as well is
there a fairness argument when you look
at what has been not said or rather not
said about operating benefits and that
their personal tax level Cuts there is
absolutely a fairness argument I I have
spoken to businesses all week and the
first thing on their mind was the
fairness argument I don't accept that
you have to trade off growth with
fairness I think you should have growth
and you should have Fair distribution of
wealth and I think that's the economy we
should be trying to build so yes I'm
absolutely as are most of the businesses
I speak to worried about the cost of
living crisis almost above everything
that's interesting what would you like
to see it happen on that well look I
think let's wait for the chancellor to
come forward I'm not going to try and
pray out what needs to come we've got
ourselves into a difficult position by
the way we were always going to I think
one of the things the public has to
accept is that if we're going to have
450 billion pounds covered bail line the
government have done a 150 billion pound
energy payout there weren't going to be
any easy choices so I cut the government
some slack for for that but I think they
need to restore fiscal credibility
exactly as you say that's to do with
inflation and debt and they need to
follow through this week and some things
that aren't very popular in conservative
circles those are the reforms that will
genuinely get the economy growing do
they also need to bring forward uh
forecasts from the office the budget
responsibility they're not due till the
end of November yes I think that's right
look as soon as they can do them the
better but let's be honest we need to
get them right and getting them right
involves the government's suggesting the
plans they want to do the obr giving
them fiscal implications of those plans
it's an iterative process so I don't
want to rush it so that it's done badly
it needs to be done well but the sooner
we see it I think the more we'll all
know where we're headed Let's cross
saying this morning that she won't be
publishing them any earlier I think
that's the right decision look I think
if it takes that long to get a good plan
take that long what you'll need to do
instead in the interim period is
demonstrate on a daily weekly basis that
you are absolutely committed to growth
that you're concerned about inflation
and debt and whatever the government can
do to give the market that reassurance
given that the markets are lending us
the money I think they'll find a way to
do that